citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to dive into a newer DC animated film
tell me John have you seen Injustice I
have not I've heard its reputation but
I've not read nor played it's all going
to be fresh to me I have not played I
have read but I have not seen so I've
only got a third of this so and
Injustice is a huge spanning story I've
only read the first two volumes It Is by
Tom Taylor it is a book I enjoy very
very much have not played the game so we
are gonna be sitting down to watch
Injustice right now and yes we know
we've been on a DC Animated Universe
kick we are not done with it but we're
like you know what let's mix it up it's
a Multiverse we're gonna dive into some
more present stuff so in the comments
let us know what else you want us to
watch let us know which the dcau which
of these standalones which of the
anything leave a comment is what I'm
saying also hit that notification Bell
so you know when we drop another one of
these the only way these get made is you
guys watching them so share with your
friends because sharing is caring you
excited for this one I'm so excited I
was also excited we will leave a like
and for people to check things out on
the patreon where you can see everything
that gets cut out of these little
highlight reels full experience of us
watching it including resting faces
that's how we watch it's pretty exciting
stuff so become a patron experience us
watching and help out the channel which
is very appreciated without further Ado
Let Us injustice
[Music]
2021 I think this is the newest one
we've watched what is the future of DC
animation look like
the recent past
that's how I love my Futures man
everything's Nostalgia this was the
intro in front of the live action movies
too right yeah
[Music]
that's what I feel like who's gonna look
like is that that scope
so bright
not for long a beautiful day
why did you say that descriptor
Metropolis
it's fun to see animation style change
in the last 10 years heavier lines
weird you're you're pregnant
oh we're pregnant we are we're pregnant
mostly you but I helped
[Laughter]
woke Superman
knows how to say it it's all you clerk
a broad world view is important but
people will notice if I'm constantly
patrolling Oxford
who's his voice
Channing Tatum who is that
not a bad choice
uh I like that it was a red blanket or a
red card because it's a little little
moment of soups he should have grabbed
the curtains threw it on this will have
to do
Injustice I'm worried at how light and
fluffy that just started
[Applause]
[Music]
The Joker isn't Metropolis I'm here to
find out why I have news Bruce
Lois is pregnant
how your hands didn't Tremble When you
faced doomsday they are now oh world's
greatest detective and you're grinning
like an idiot
say cheese
looks suspicious
everyone wear glasses you don't look
suspicious enough
one more
[Music]
whoa imagine meeting you here hello
vacation is so fun pudding only the very
best for you that's how they tie this
yeah
oh wow oh wow
through the lens koi we did these are
supposed to be fun we did warn you
it's a light story from the DC Universe
oh Superman watch he has her help me
please
right to business I need as many of you
as we can spare a metropolis a woman is
missing you want the whole Justice
League on a missing person yes what's up
Green Arrow yeah who is this woman
Batman she's one of ours her name is
Lois Lane one of us one of us
flash we're searching for Lois Lane in
Metropolis straight out of the show that
was cool I need you to search everything
Underground
said burn Ave John Byrne one of the
great DC and Marvel artists hey
my man
I found scarecrow he's dead Joker toxin
his lab has been ransacked
bummer something's wrong oh no
oh yeah
[Music]
love it
oh wow
wow
they just jigsawed Barry Allen
stolen a submarine with Harley Quinn
they took Lois with them oh my god get
Aquaman on the case yeah where's he at
[Music]
a little Snyder left for you yeah yeah
and a little Superman and Lois
where is she no
no I will not let you hurt anyone oh
scarecrow's fear toxin mixed with
Kryptonite particles
what did you
it'll be my masterpiece
Superman stop whatever you're seeing
it's not real
oh god
oh no please don't tell me
oh my God
what is what's the scar
[Music]
oh
God why'd you tell me about this coin
that was that that was the moment I was
like well let's see how John takes this
we started out so joyous
and it escalates from here so uh well
Justice we're just gonna break through
the ceiling all the way down into hell
yeah this has always been about us
why do this to him I thought I'd try a
game on easy mode for once
as easy as beating a puppy to death with
a kitten
I killed him no
that madman orchestrated this he's
responsible will you keep her safe of
course what what is there to keep safe
now I mean you want to honor her I Fair
sorry I'm so distraught I mean you
should be it's got so many feelings
you've had an unfathomable loss you need
time to process it
oh yeah
is this Hal yeah please don't do
something you'll regret for the rest of
your life
I already have
uh oh someone took everything from you
didn't they and look at what you became
what do you think he'll become a God who
deluded himself into believing he was
just a man
the joke's on you and the world
oh my God
I think uh murder him right here
[Laughter]
um
Comics are for kids oh yeah Comics are
wholesale and video games are fanciful
this is a video game and a comic what a
story
I'm gonna try and contain myself the
punchline line that image from the comic
is so like super punching The Joker Is
Such like a comic moment sure I'm gonna
go grab the comic immediately it's so
good Tom Taylor
keeping a low profile
[Music]
oh yeah get ready for a permanent low
profile
[Music]
yep just got it the the double meaning
of that joke
I feel like that would still hurt to get
hit in the nuts with them yeah
so where are we going to a secret
location I won't be secret for Long hey
how come your little beard looks both
ridiculous and cute
what's this one do
well done Hawkeye
he's got the skills Jamie Renner
threat of instant nuclear death hanging
over every single one of us new killer
new killer glad he's doing this oh how
many times did you catch this Joker your
laws are weak and ineffective Twisted by
evil people to escape just punishment
I mean not a bad argument you'll throw
away everything the Justice League
stands for I won't be held back by
ideals that don't protect the innocent
you're grieving
we were wrong
beautiful psychology and character use
and like what a story
and beautiful anime beautiful animation
Superman and Wonder Woman deposited
president Hussein at the Hague for trial
well that happened
yep where I am
you're in the arrow cave Arrow cave is a
stupid name though
Batman has the bat cave that makes sense
bats live in caves arrows don't uh
Whatchamacallit inanimate okay
call it the quiver call it the Quivers
it goes that's actually much better
that's so annoying
I love that 50 years in the era the
quiver monsters will not be allowed to
roam free finally quiet
[Laughter]
sorry
plastic man's the best
no one has the right to take innocent
lives no one
it's over
[Music]
can we talk about how you took the
innocent life of your badass five
o'clock shadow
it was beautiful Superman and Wonder
Woman destroyed every piece of military
equipment declaring it an arms free zone
this is like the boys if they were still
moral somehow right kind of
yeah there's characters you know like
it's a fascinating this is so Palestine
Superman
crime and you and Superman decide these
punishment
I believe my time with the Justice
League is over
oh most of the magical Heroes feel the
same way everyone has to make their own
choice about this at last
we agree on something
I want to hear what Mr terrific had to
say is the smartest man
Justice for terrific Sterling K Brown
live-action Mr terrific make it happen
James Gunn
here
oh
and that's when the boy scout crashed
our tea party what do you propose Bob
this is tricky it's crazy right yeah
whoa on the floor old man
was that necessary
everyone get to me for Evac now
it is upon myself and I just check me
out real quick through this badassery
here where is he alive he stays that way
if you stop interfering with governments
father is the last link to my Humanity
if I lose him
let your friends help you are you really
helping them hey what's up
where's Gary King exactly
time to talk personal space your
highness nah why don't you walk out of
here and do it slow for me well there's
no place to hide prove it
hey nice
you have to understand I had orders the
kind you can't say no to where's
Jonathan Kent
Bolivia was that like a Suicide Squad
mission for him
oh I wonder if that is that the kind of
order you can't say no to yeah ten
square kilometers of endless reflected
sky so beautiful
[Music]
ah that was dope nice it was incredibly
stupid you do not touch a man's parents
he wouldn't touch me the public
perception really that naive there'd be
no evidence and no one will think to
look for your body on Saturn dude
have you been here for the past 20
minutes come on now
you're trying to hurt your opponents
which I'm trying not to take personally
I was taught by the League of Assassins
in racial ghoul yeah how's that working
out for you
how are you is he here yeah and broodier
than usual we'll give you some space
come on Damien
oh yeah you killed a man Clark not
a man
a monster we can't decide who dies one
death it always starts with one
your parents were murdered Bruce
they couldn't be there for you what's
your excuse
oh boy oh show me your hand
come on don't be you
Airline fracture of the third finger
you'll be fine in three weeks good to
know
jeez
I'd like you to be there at my side I'm
sorry Clark I can't do that
can we watch absolutely Amish now I'm
dying to see if goody and finishes her
spice rack buffer rum spiringer
hahaha
that delivery was so good
you're spying on me through my TV for
how long that's unimportant not to me
sure he's taking him we're out of time
I've decided to move the worst criminals
to a secure facility they won't threaten
anyone again oh boy as long as we're
going to help Superman burn Arkham to
the ground you're 13. how old is the
darkest thing in this cave
ever considered for a single second that
you might be wrong father well have you
I've spent like a lifetime considering
this Damien I just love the different
perspectives so quickly yeah yeah and it
makes perfect sense that Damien would be
on Superman's side yeah young
impressional angry you were never as
stubborn as him
God to be that stubborn a person has to
be directly related to you
now let's go defend a bunch of psychotic
killers from the world's greatest heroes
bars
Tom Taylor's currently writing Nightwing
the guy that wrote this in the first
place and it's the best Nightwing's been
in years it's so good I'm coming with to
bring Superman to Justice or die trying
either or because I'm a hero now hero
Harley oh yep yep
yep are you insane let me answer that
question with an action that reveals
character what oh oh dude no
such chaos
what are you doing bringing criminals to
Justice I'm standing with Superman look
who you're standing with Bane Killer
Croc and whoever that is uh calendar man
is important in one Arc
Superman's got a scar now don't you do
you feel it the release that comes with
it the freedom to do anything you want
oh is that jazz yeah making a point
Victor zaz
David sass laugh
where are you taking them all you need
to know is that it's escape proof oh my
all right Riddler time to go
EMP the bat bad EMP you'd always be
ready to take on the league the data
stamp on the virus
you uploaded it the day we met what
that's low sure
oh
no oh no
I recommend putting aside our
differences for now
oh boy Clayface
extremely painful for me
there's your guy there's your guy born
on a Monday
oh
no your guy if you harm one hair on I
mean aside from the hand it's still
clenching
that's awesome
damn it Joe manganillo I think that was
Will Smith Oh Deadshot sorry it's okay
it's okay I got you you're not Bobby
oh
[Laughter]
yeesh Nightwing
Gracie get up hello the greatest Duo of
all time
[Music]
he won't be coming back on a Monday
could be your Frankenstein zombie guy
always
get away from him oh
is he actually dead I thought I could
redeem you
I was wrong
yeah don't bother coming back to the bat
cave
I'm exhausted we should we should pause
I've been playing this as a game and
like just enduring Nightwing is dead
he'll need someone
you're his best friend talk to him
I can't
too much has happened I love how well it
knows the characters like Superman would
still try
yeah no this is this is lovely in a lot
of ways and the characterizations and
the debates yeah the psychology of right
and wrong and stop
stop John Wick chapter four
don't be Batman don't be the mask
let it out just for tonight let yourself
fall apart oh those lyrics
sound like lyrics oh Beth
almost made me cry right there
one for all the more you know
bummer
bummer it's all okay now welcome to
Grayson I ramakrishna hey
you must transform to Grace is Dick
Grayson gonna become dead man
where's my man Boston
your soul shall be infused
your mind with my knowledge
Moon Knight
[Laughter]
but now you shall be called
dead
wig
that away
all right I take it back it was worth
him dying
payoff always kill him if he's gonna be
coming
I offer my loyalty and my support
your vision of the future
my grandfather has never bowed to anyone
this is a big deal you should know
that's uh it's kind of a thing I'd never
Ally myself with a Villain Like You how
do we change his mind we wait time and
Circumstance will change Superman's mind
for us and I will be ready
how very Zen of you
I mean he lives a long time you gotta
you learn to come
I'm trying to map the Multiverse there
are infinite Earths oh well we designate
our Earth Earth One it stands to reason
that our other selves would do the same
and they're all in crisis
I want to get rid of guns you could
never get rid of all the guns
people would resent us and they'd be
alive to do that check
some would fight
let them come then with sticks
and visual metaphors
and imprison anyone who speeds
traffic fatalities are huge
check lock up everyone who leaves a
dangerous dog Unchained oh
finally we kill anyone who doesn't
recycle
yes we're Swamp Thing at he's down how
great is Mr terrific you're not going to
help me no sir I am not oh dude I love
that character so much uh yeah I want
more
cool
the bath cave
behave Harley
in the Fortress of Solitude there's a
red Sun Cannon it's rake and
incapacitate even Superman can we back
up toward the thing that we need is in
Superman's man cave we'll have to break
in hello Christmas morning
your president is using a piece for his
purposes
[Music]
we never learn America what are you
doing
I don't want to waste time turning those
ships around when you can do it with a
phone call you can't just oh yeah yes I
can
yes we can you must know I wouldn't let
it stand
you're distracting me
[Music]
glad that's over
let's go there for a second you say
impenetrable Fortress all I hear is
candy store
that's right every line of dialogue does
so much like character building flexing
like they're so good at this you should
go quickly we're leaving what about the
fate of the world Superman's not
thinking clearly if he thinks even for a
moment that would
God
oh man
you're all under arrest I don't think so
the atom has entered your skull with a
microscopic Shard of kryptonite wow
you'll make sure you don't do anything
else wow
perhaps
I can be of assistance oh
damn it breathe This is highly
concentrated chemotherapeutic gas oh no
of course
the microscopic terrorists
[Applause]
whoa this is gonna be floating around in
his head forever mushy just living there
what's left of the atom
[Music]
oh
what
oh no dad
no
[Music]
oh my God let them go it was an accident
try and forgive them
oh
I love you son
oh they must be brought to Justice allow
me to help
it's just
from now on any hero that doesn't pledge
loyalty to the Justice League will be
considered a fugitive wow fascist man
it is driving me nuts trying to figure
out it's like so specific like I can
almost see it Superman has greeted a
police state and Allied himself with
raishal ghoul
not what I wanted
yeah that's pretty bad what I wanted
[Laughter]
like it's so Grim in certain parts but
so fun in other ways so good so good
[Music]
you're gathering in his name
[Applause]
oh boy
and that's the last annual Gathering of
the Juggalos
[Laughter]
homelander stop absolute power
Green Arrow was hurt and you left him
there he had a hole in his head
try me yeah yeah well they just got
snacks and it's
the saddest meeting in the Justice
League it's the Justice League now it's
where they're at the beef jerky League
to free their inventor Mr terrific from
Superman's prison I've learned it's
located in the Marianas Trench
wow
there's only one hero not allied with
Superman who has the powers to get there
he's been hiding here for days ah you
knew
[Laughter]
please hey ladies oh my oh I give you a
meso
imagine one of these in every city in
town carrying out your orders in every
household
Amazon tested in a small town Amazon's
Amazo
named meso did racial goal name Amanda I
feel like you could have shopped that
Ben shorts for Plastic Man you
now
hey look I found the key
that's handy
[Music]
let's go
we need to break the glass I thought you
were like the third smartest man in the
world it's keeping the water out
[Laughter]
you know what you're doing
don't move we're out
there's one problem solved now the
trench would flood pretty much
immediately that's that's pretty deep
thick
so cool dick is always a highlight man
yeah it's just awesome always like
permanently awesome any form
flattered but nice tattoo though it's
not a tattoo oh
it's a it's a stick on tattoo it's an
iPad okay this thing looks really thin
is it strong enough probably probably
thank you
playing around the world
you killed these children
because they angered you no I killed
them because the lesson had to be
learned I have to be strong
you said it's an interesting dynamic
between these two specifically yeah the
woman like
the Corn Festival the old Corn Fest
oh oh
that's the small town you want to test
out a Mesa win
my dude
I should hope
to say Earl past the woe is the kid who
swiped a candy bar
oh
destroy him that's it oh
wow wow
America
the flag behind him and everything
oh
Potential Threat to Authority Corn Fest
is ruined it's popcorn Fest now
take the robot offline now it's
malfunctioning Amazo is functioning
perfectly it is you you who are not
what I neglected to tell you is that it
can also duplicate your ability
oh yeah
boy
[Music]
am I maybe glad to see you
I'm conflicted
yeah oh well
that's metal Amazon
[Music]
that's a dead fan agarium that is rough
that was
like a Hawkman even spoke
like a Grindhouse movie
is the cratering alone
wow
oh boy
[Music]
oh no
oh
my man
can he breathe in space
I don't think he breathes
we'll keep the thing occupied you're a
freaking guy in a suit
everyone needs to follow the plan
foreign
yes Queen
he's my father
disappoint me
no I guess that's just the way it is
with family not bad Damian
oh boy more powerful than a locomotive
oh
proof
in the pudding there it is cool
we need Plastic Man
sweet
oh cool you is it really you in the
spiritual flesh
sure
that's awesome you've got this boy it's
just like building blocks
yeah
well done
third level medium
oh boy
[Music]
oh nice that's a whip animation
oh
[Music]
Carly
whoa
oh my God oh my God
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's what you got to do sometimes
sit back and let me do this
wait for it
[Music]
there you go you're better than I am
you always were I've gotta go now watch
your feet and remember you don't have to
kill everyone you fight
hahaha
I'll try it your way
you two no the battle is one is it
at least they died Heroes unlike you
terrorists who will go to jail for your
crimes
what might
they helped us
Stand Down
finally stop this madness
be a freaking hero
[Music]
huh
39 Superman
actually we're worth one what are we 22.
everyone's Earth one I'm deeply sorry
for your losses but you're on the wrong
side of this no one is talking me out of
this yeah we can be stubborn sometimes
oh yeah
yep yep
oh my God
oh yeah
some of this is Gonna Knock the Earth
out of its orbit right
oh my God this goes so freaking hard
ah
I can't you're holding back
you always held back oh nice nice POV
[Music]
Oppenheimer yeah that would be the
concern
one holds back you think I'll stop
because someone will talk me out of it
yes
yep hello Clark
oh other Lois oh no
oh my you're not Lois
and you're not my Clark
he died stopping Brainiac
oh my how many people
husbands wives and children will you
kill for peace Clark
yep
just posing what have I done
oh man I deserve death you don't get off
that easy
you deserve justice I'll stay wherever
you put me
oh
buddy maybe we've all earned a second
chance
oh what's gotten into you
just let it happen be in the moment PDA
Batman
[Music]
flat line
oh
wow Injustice I am I am wrong Out Boy
I am Justin Hartley that's who Superman
was an Anson Mel's Batman Mount okay
Justin Hartley interesting where would I
know Justin Hartley uh Eastern Mrs us
which is where I know I'm from okay okay
he was Green Arrow on uh Smallville okay
uh oh wait no it's the Aquaman I think
he was Aquaman either way he was in the
Smallville era he's on the Smallville uh
I yeah this is us is like my main thing
from knowing him okay okay
damn she's good yeah absolutely
that was intense that was a whole Yuri
was a Shazam Flash and mirror Master
look at all these like multicast these
are talented voice actors Jillian Jacobs
is Harley Quinn and Kevin Pollock is the
Joker damn hell yeah not bad Janet
Varney is a Wonder Woman
that was so intense that was yeah
overwhelming in a good way and yeah like
a fun way but also like yeah just like I
am exhausted a little bit they came at
you yeah and like it's it's Relentless
and and it does I think it plays really
well on the themes so that like if you
didn't know these characters at all it
would still work as like a debate and
just like an impossible situation but
also knowing I mean you know you know
the characters like super intimately I
know the characters to varying degrees
but even still just having all those
notes in there it does hit that much
harder because they do seem at least
from from my point of view so good at
using yeah like the intrinsic qualities
of the characters to inform all that
others yeah and to create the ironies
and the tragedies and Tom Taylor just
plays chess like he's playing such a
long game with all these characters
they're all doing their different
purposes and everything like builds and
builds and builds like every single
character that spoke had a beautiful
moment of like what they are and what
their worldview is and it's not just
like a one-to-one it's like a one to
Thirty like there's so many perspectives
on every situation which is real life
yeah like he masterfully handles DC
characters yeah that was gorgeous and
and yeah for another like these movies
are all like at least under you know an
hour 20 and like this felt so thick it
just felt like a longer movie in a good
way yeah you feel like you got the arcs
you needed to to justify these moments
yeah you feel like you got emotion you
feel like you got you know ideas and
stuff you even got freaking humor amid
all this Grim crazy so many moments of
levity that you need to enjoy the
experience of like oh yeah it's like
this was like the most maybe not the
no it's pretty dark like yeah you know
you we watched uh justice league dark
last week and I mean that had like when
you whenever you go hellish yeah there
was like certain dark yeah yeah it's
like not exactly there is Horror in this
but this isn't yeah as horror-centric of
aesthetic as that is but yeah like this
is philosophically harv yeah no 100 like
in a in a different way than something
like the boys is because that's also
like at the you know satirical like
everyone's irreverent and but like
you know this is like what if you know
the uh for the most part quintessential
versions of these characters as they are
were put into these uh ideological
positions to use their powers in such
devastating ways and so yeah it's like
it's not the same as watching a
homelandering like merch but it does
happen sort of like Oh and it does play
into that conversation in an interesting
way and I love the escalation of like
what he's willing to do how that changes
how it evolves how he sees wrong and how
that changes and evolves and I love
Batman's always like
Batman's wrong about a lot of things in
my opinion but that's my opinion and I
love that Batman gets to stay like a
moral compass in this story because
everyone else like he's our only eye
line he's our only like True North yeah
and that's really fun because like you
you don't identify with a lot of
characters but you've got like Batman
and I I love that Batman can be that
yeah totally and and I think it's it's a
it's a nice human element because I
think who's it Plastic Man uh at one
point says that thing about like you're
just a guy in a suit do you like the
rest of us are powered and and so I
think that combined with the fact that
sure he is human he's wrong sometimes he
does you know let his like it's a great
Counterpoint that Superman should be
blinded by rage Vengeance and hurt Etc
because yeah like Bruce making these
ideological arguments like yeah he's not
perfect but also I think that bolsters
his position in a way it's actually
really funny that this is the comic I'm
about to reference because it's also
written by Tom Taylor this dude's
incredible uh last month's uh There's a
comic I've told you about before called
Batman one bad day and I reference
Riddler before last month the final
issue of the seven issue Anthology
series they're not connected at all each
one is its own thing but it just happens
to be seven things yeah uh was Rochelle
ghoul and it was written by Tom Taylor
and it was basically how he's kind of
right and how Batman is wrong to his
extremism and it was really cool because
it almost plays like an uh the opposite
of Injustice Superman's not involved in
it but it's seeing how a villain's
perspective has a greater overall good
than Batman's and it was really cool to
read a Batman story where like hey your
extremism about not doing these things
is costing the world and rash Al ghoul
and it's a fascinating comic book and
like it was really cool to watch this
because I don't know Tom Taylor wrote
like seven volumes of this this keeps
going like there's like there's 100 plus
yeah and like there's there's I think
two video games and then like seven
volumes of books wow so I think he's
written like upwards of hundreds of
issues of this story and um I didn't
know like after a point how this ended
so it was really cool for me to like
watch this and know how it started and
then like at a point I don't know where
it went so it was really cool for me to
be like oh right I I stopped here yeah
like this was so fascinating so you get
the dual yeah
that's 30 minutes being like he doesn't
know and then like it just escalates and
then at some point being like Oh God I
don't know yeah no that was so much that
we could each exist yeah I really
enjoyed the opening where I was like he
doesn't have duck this is gonna get very
soon because the opening is like so
heavy and then it's just it gets worse
so dark so heavy and and two like God
yeah Joker gets taken out like right
away and yet like this is all it all
kind of has set him like yeah they're
really good at kind of pinning down the
geography to where you're not thinking
necessarily of him but you're like wow
this was this was the one bad day and
all of the cascading circumstances that
came out of that and all Joker needed to
do was change tactics and it's like a
master plan like it
Batman by way of Superman like yeah and
and The Ensemble of characters they they
chose here was lovely too like I mean
and also sorry last thing about Joker I
love that the Joker's suicidal so that
works so well for that choice for the
character like that really made me happy
to see Joker be like this is what I've
always wanted and I get to destroy the
world through Batman like it's so forget
to get the answer oh man like his
ultimate joke no yeah
like and that image in the comic book
like it's just I love that his last word
is punchline
because he punched through that no like
it's it is like Chef's kit like there's
so many Magic flourishes that that could
only exist in like an else worlds kind
of scenario like this and I like that
they even go so far as to be like here's
a little Multiverse I also like that
they're like we all sing for Earth one
because that like that is what everyone
would think like I would be like yeah
we're once the rest and Liberty's like
that's kind of what we do uh The
Ensemble though like you got to meet Mr
terrific you got to meet people plastic
man you got to meet like a lot of really
cool like It's tricky because I wouldn't
say A and B list but like less uh
awareness like a lot of people don't
know these characters I'm I'm yeah it's
like Plastic Man as a character I've
seen yeah but I wouldn't have been able
to like identify and uh and uh Mr
terrific like yeah he's uh yeah like I
want more of I just want to see more of
that character
yeah in an animated movie that's now in
20 minutes long and Mr like that I love
that this is let's go philosophy no it's
like this movie was like let's go
anything anything we're trying to do
let's go like I I was I was talking
about face off the other day and I was
like part of what makes this movie work
is that anything it decides to be at any
given moment it is going full force at
that and this different way different
kind of thing but like this has that
where yeah anything we're doing like
even the little romantic moments yeah
like kind of romantic or touching or
like when it's actually emotional like
when when Catwoman Comforts Batman like
that's that's like really set like there
were a couple times where this got me I
didn't like cry but I was I did get
Misty and I didn't like get tears in my
eyes forming up and I was like Wow even
on top of all this other you know all
the other ways this movie is hitting you
also have that and like Superman's pain
and anguish and the way that they
amplify his grief and show that like
when you're grieving and you have the
wrong people in your ear yes so many bad
things can happen and sometimes the
wrong people are people like Wonder
Woman Who are your colleagues or who
people you trust and then you have like
your racial ghouls who are going to and
he wouldn't be on his side mentally
broke to a point like you break and
break and break and like one bad
decision leads to another I like how
it's causality it's not just like oh
Rochelle ghoul I I get his perspective
no no he had to get to that point and
that's very human and I love that and
elsewhere what I think else worlds do
best when they're good a lot of
Elsewhere alternate but when elseworld
is good it shows the trueness of the
character because you see how one tweak
changes the character but you believe in
them to such a level like all of the
supporting characters and even
Superman's choices that only makes our
Superman better that only makes our
taking those characters better because
you see all these different angles of
them yeah yeah and like it was really
well conceived of and well fleshed out
just for all those turns that needed to
happen and I love that as much as so
much of this is in your face uh like
especially the Superman and Wonder Woman
relationship was had this like oddly
fascinating tone where so much of it
you're watching it and going like
she is not leading you in the right
direction like she's not encouraging you
in the right direction like there are so
many early moments where you're like if
if you weren't like bolstering his
position right now he might regret a
little bit and ease up on him and she's
going this is the piece that I have
always sought and she doesn't she
doesn't believe that Superman can go bad
yeah she thinks that Superman's so
incorruptable that he is the one to
solve the problem she sees so much
goodness in Clark that she thinks that
this is going to be a net positive even
at cost like that's and that's great
writing yeah oh yeah and and I mean
those little twists of the knife like it
reminded me of the whole um Martha Wayne
Joker thing yeah when you have just
these like especially with Lois up top
but but all the yeah just different
twists on the familiar circumstances
that then Paul saying don't do this
thing but then because Russia's there
rash wouldn't be there without the
Wonder Woman being there Wonder won't be
there she didn't believe in Clark Clark
wouldn't have been believable if he
hadn't been Clark those years like it's
so many like it's genius yeah yeah and
then watching Batman have to be like
Clark you're you're not you're not me
learn the lessons I already he learned
my dude and even fighting another
Superman like he wouldn't hold back so
he would be stronger than Superman
because Superman holds back like genius
oh yeah well and two I feel like it's
interesting people dog on on Damien
Wayne I feel like he has such purpose
yeah I don't know at least as of these
movies like I feel like when they
announce the Brave and the Bold and
James goes like he's my favorite Robin I
feel like people kind of dogpiled that
but I'm like through these movies I have
loved his Arc and the continuity but
also something like this that is clearly
you know very much in line with all of
that and then the stuff that goes down
between him and dick well I love that to
me I've I've talked about not actually
maybe you'll make a koi's comic Corner
about this because I've talked about how
the reason I love Batman's Rogues is
their him one bad day away from whatever
and how they have that same passion what
I love about his Robins is they're all
the alternate realities of Bruce's
childhood call yeah so like the
adulthood is the villains the childhood
is the Robins
ah so I love personally the psychology
of Batman displacing his own belief
system into these children and how
someone that didn't have a childhood
would do that and how Batman displacing
his anger is at adulthood and at the
villains oh that's a that's right that's
some depth right there I should make a
video because I that's something I've
I've played with narrative yeah and I
think it'd be interesting to dive into
it's because it's thematic right aspect
yeah and like because Nightwing
represents his maturation into becoming
like it's like puberty it's your cool
you're edgy and you actually find
yourself and you know um the Innocence
Lost of Red Hood and like wow how you
know that took over and you never had
the ability to mature in Nightwing and
he represents the Rage of
pre-adolescence he represents that
youthful you know vindictiveness that
comes from feeling slighted by the world
like they're all youthful emotions so
the robins are his Youth and the
villains are is adult and I and I love
that yeah and like just his aligning
with Superman in that position made so
so much sense yeah and two the whole
ramakrishna
thing it was again like a a beautiful
sort of cosmic Fantastical left turn the
world because they've established dead
man like you you said like hello and
yeah I was like I was hoping for for
dead man himself just because
discovering that character in justice
league dark was such a joy but then yeah
to get the to be so upset that they
would dare kill off uh dick and then to
be rewarded with like he's cool in this
form too yeah which which made up for I
like long hair Dick Grayson I mean a
little bit uh and not to say that the
haircut is bad but I was just like oh
man is my dad grow it out dude and then
you look great but yeah having him come
back in that capacity and the whole
thing where he has to you know possess
Damien and they have to fight as one and
then you can see him after that because
of that it's just like so many people
only two beats felt rushed in this whole
thing and one was the The Dick Grayson
Damien moment just felt like he he
Damien fought it
nine tenths out of the way I would have
loved a little back and forth and like a
dick having a little say and then the
very end obviously they were like we
gotta rapid 200 20 minutes but like uh
oh but overall the pacing's so
incredible in this because like this
comic is so long and they told it an
hour and 20. and it's also so deep and
dense like you said like it feels longer
very few moments felt rushed and that's
impressive for how much they did yeah
and they still managed to like have fun
with it yeah well we speaking of Russian
we got to wrap this up uh this was so
much fun I love this this is in
contention for my top three uh this was
so special it's gonna be so hard to rank
these we're gonna try we're gonna keep
watching them we know this was more
recent we know this wasn't dcau but we
were going to be going back to that I
think next
um but we're gonna play around with this
and if you guys want to see any certain
ones again leave a comment below hit
that like hit that notification if you
want to see me do that my um philosophy
and psychology of Batman let me know
because I think that'd be fun and uh
anything else in that vein let us know
and as ever please do share this video
this is always fun much love to you
reject Nation we Audi
yeah
but before we leave future John has to
edit this into this video somewhere I
want to give a very special super sexy
Patron shout out to a cool name that I
saw and I was like this is this is uh I
got a little zasket a little flavor
pandemic Jones I'm gonna give some love
in this name because one pandemic
inherently negative word but especially
lately uh you know we lived through one
Jones very keeping up with the Joneses
makes me think Americana makes me think
it's almost like the more flavorful
Smith it's got a little of the uh you
know it's it's a neutral leaning
positive and the philosophy of Keeping
Up With the Jones is is really
interesting because it's about finding
yourself not Material items so I really
appreciate pandemic something inherently
negative with Jones which I think of is
inherently positive so you're combining
this the name itself has this very
interesting Duality and dichotomy of
belief so pandemic Jones I like your
name
that was beautiful
I want to be assessed that way ever yeah
just having that what do you
representing I was like that was a whole
beautiful I was like Smith and Jones
reminds me of Doctor Who okay so you got
John Humphrey right you got John which
is the name